Dick Gregory author of callous on my
soul where did you get the name for this
book I got callus on my feet no I just
had was thinking that your feet has made
a universal god force and your feet
fourth of all the bones in your body is
in your feet now someone would have told
me that when I was a little child I
never would have wore tight shoes just
cause they look good with the outfit I
think a fourth of all the bones so I got
to thinking he's look at his old black
men and then once I became famous and
could travel I noticed something my old
Jewish waiters in New York City I mean
it looked like the shoes they wore the
high tops and look like it had soup on
it from the first day 40 years ago but I
notice all the shoes had holes little
cuts and they was turned up and and then
I realized thinking those old black men
and women who had calluses who didn't
know there was such thing as a foot
doctor okay and you noticed that they
would cut to Hue and then I realized
we're not looking in old shoes they were
still wearing out from the inside and
then one day it dawned on me they have
never been a hue that a human have made
that could wear out a pair of God's feet
so if you wear tights you you get a
little rub you get a blister and you get
a coin you get a callus and thinking
that a callus will wear a shoe out and I
realize that black folks are press folks
we have a callus around our soul and if
you don't cut that shoe the hue will be
wore out from the inside now the
significance of this is I have no
control over that I don't care how much
I like this you there's a universal God
full
that says you can't rub me like this
without me reacting and so I'm saying to
America that we have a callus around our
soul and have nothing to do with me
being polite or trying to peacefully
coexist there's nothing I can do in my
automobile I'm so busy I can't stop for
gas when it runs out it stops and I
think in America no one in the history
of this planet have made the progress
that we African Americans have made in a
thirty year period now let me say this
again in the history of this planet
there have been no one to make the
progress that applicant Americans have
made and the 30 appeared in spite of
black folks and white folks lying to one
another not being fair not being honest
in some kind of way racism is so fragile
racism is a punk offenses you and I
driving down the highway you have your
grandchild I have mine the cost gear and
turnover three black militant talking
crack of this and crocodile and three
crew club planners come over and both of
groups is lifting that car up I do not
see your Klan sheet nor do you hear the
word cracker that's how fragile I used
to hit black men coming back from World
War two and talking about how nice
things was doing war and I was too young
to understand how fragile racism is and
they talked about when there's over the
front line of battle how they smoke off
the same sigil on the same pipe eat out
the same food and then after the war was
over when it took my gun that called me
a [ __ ] and I was back well at that
point I was too busy listening to old
folks talk then to realize what they
were saying whether they knew it or not
racism prejudice is so fragile that you
can suspend it so anything I can suspend
is not real in the first place where do
you live today I live in Plymouth
Massachusetts why Plymouth I think I
think that the appeal was gonna come
back again I got some Indians we gonna
stop them this time hey wait hold it
wait a minute wait no no it's very
interesting I have ten children and I
was looking for a place to raise them
because you know coming up poor coming
up in a ghetto coming up in a racist
system you have so many things to do
that you can see that it never dawned on
me there was things that you couldn't
see that will kill you just as fast like
polluted water polluted air you can't
see smell or taste or feel radiation and
one day I was arrested in Chicago for a
demonstration and in the process of my
arrest I would always go to jail and I
said well I'm not in jail for committing
a crime so I don't think I should be
punished
I don't mind going to jail so I'm not
going to do no work detail and that
would aggravate people who was even
thought what she was doing was right but
now you are my turf and so I wouldn't do
anything and it saved my life that's why
I say this movement owe me nothing you
know I came through the awful thing
about being poor is you get hung up with
wanting to get from here to there and
don't know what they went through you
you see this luxury but you don't know
if it was an insurance fraud you don't
know if if a wife or husband died in a
plane wreck and that's how the money you
just see the luxury and you want to get
there and I'm laying in bed in jail and
I'm not sleep I'm fast I always refused
to eat when I go to
drinking water and laying there I had
this vision that Chicago was on fire it
was kind of interesting cause I always
felt there was something wrong with mrs.
O'Leary's cow I mean if you think about
how sexism affects our society today
can you imagine what sexy when did where
does she get them calls from I mean mrs.
O'Leary's cow so I used to do a lot is
it wasn't but what happened is mr.
O'Leary got drunk and went out in the
barn and milk the bull by mistake that's
what caused the fog so I'm thinking that
what I'm there seen his vision as
Chicago's on fire but I don't see no
flames and I'm caught up I see this guy
standing at the door a white guy
but a little smirky grin on his face and
so I come out of it now and I really
wanted to tell myself I'd been sleeping
and I hadn't been my wife was in the
hospital having our 10th child and when
I got out of jail I just realized I had
to get out Chicago
something was going to happen I didn't
know what it meant she called was
burning but there's no flame so we moved
to Chicago we live in a fantastic
neighborhood wanted to find
neighborhoods in America because it's
the University of Chicago hi parked in
wood and these two run ads in Newsweek
you know listen to Gregory bum
ba-da-da-da-da it was the highest
per-capita education wise of the people
who live there but I noticed something
just snooping around looking at news
right a block from where I live is fine
incredible neighborhood about 200 days
out the year whatever you used to call
the cold for bad air day that area would
have it
you said the lake is across the street
and so we got out now how do I get to
Plymouth and I'll come back and finish
Chicago I wanted to find a farm I wanted
to find a place where the children could
have fresh air clean water and and grow
a little plant or something not nothing
serious you know I tell you I was making
too much money to be a farmer
so I had some friends looking and I
looked at so many places so fast I
thought I was moving to Providence Rhode
Island and I went I had I had told the
lawyers and I'm thinking I'm buying the
house I didn't know it's leased and they
kept saying and yeah you you hear what
you want to hear so lil got out the
hospital with baby number ten and we
packed up everything and it was under
protests and a seat I've never
understood why parent specially fathers
get uptight with their children because
every scheme in that house was financed
by me
i'ma argue with you I might yell at you
I just give me a good book and sitting
from the refrigerator and at some time
that day you will come that way because
that's where all the food is and then
you will find out whose food this is and
then I want to know why I have to call
you so many times and you don't hear me
so we head out and nobody's laughing no
one and we get there I'm at the wrong
place a lake I can't swim lil kesh well
so they rebelled seriously Robair it and
I didn't care except I'm so embarrassed
I'm at the wrong place so I take them in
town and shut them in a hotel so I can
gather my thoughts so I go can you
imagine
400 acres around Lake I go and have a
guy come put a fence up
quickly for the fence up now you
protected so we come back they move in
and no one stays angry long so then they
but all at once have children born and
raised in Chicago that only way to the
playground when you visit friends they
walk through dope pushers prostitutes
people cussing taverns bars we get to a
farm they scared of butterflies man
they're running they go get us a little
your problem with just left I cared my
son to Mexico one year he's four years
old and the area I go to had no electric
no life they didn't want it they just
was just ruled nothing just there and
you lived in a hut you lapa Mexico and
he runs in hauling and screaming they
don't get me in and I run outside I'm
not one of these fathers that will run
outside just cause that's my boy I can
tell where he's Hollywood none serious
but I've told all my children my wife if
anything happens you know seriously call
the ponies do I'm not a pitbull somebody
do don't wait till I come home call the
police yeah so I go outside with stars
stars and I felt so bad I was born 1932
no pollution just lay out on your back
with a piece of straw in your mouth you
know win the city and cooks out the Big
Dipper that's mine and just you'll see
shooting stars
what city st. Louis so now 1963 I have a
child born in a city and have never seen
a star huh
to pollute it too many lights too bright
that didn't bother me what bothered me
and made me cry I was born seeing stars
and I've been so busy in the rat race in
the hustle and the bustle
I never told me they left Oh huh and I
really was ashamed you know it's one
thing never having something it's
nothing you have something that book
sitting on your lap and then all the
once it's moving you didn't know it was
gone and so all of these led me into the
only rule I said when I was looking for
a place was find me a place of our from
a major airport because at that time
about 80 to 90% of my work was College
lectures in 80% of all colleges is east
of the Rockies and so as long as I'm
hours from the airport I'm and Plymouth
is an hour from the Boston Airport that
was the only criteria I had so we get
there and 400 acres everybody's happy I
felt bad my friends say you growing
anything you know I said oh this is a
rich boy farm it's just you know so it's
manicured it's a I had the only admires
estate and President Cleveland used to
go up and it was a horse farm and they
have only these huge places and it was
just gorgeous and so we planted a garden
that's the first time I really ever
played father we out digging the dirt
it's not growing see little onion come
up and then all at once we ordered the
swing you know the whole swing the whole
apparatus from Sears and Roebuck we had
all of everything the children play with
right and out of 400 acres when I got
back home out of all the places for the
put that they put in the garden so I
said well we might as well give up
there's no
armistice there's no rule listen I'm in
trouble
you got 400 acres the only place that's
it oh god help me please help me and so
that's how I ended up in a in Plymouth
you've been married to but wait let me
please let me do this
about three years later just thumbing
through some research I see something
and what he's like secret reports that
one of the highest strangest forms of
bone cancer deaths anywhere on the
planet is in this area where I used to
live huh Chicago or a plumber Chicago
not just Chicago hi Park
Kim wood huh so I'm saying to my wife
little wait a minute
this is the vision this strange bone
cancer so I check it out and I find out
at Stagg field 55th and Cottage Grove is
when they split the atom he's the pride
myself was showing friends you know this
is where the atom was split and they
found it was still radiated he cuts tag
field down and it's a track I used to
tell people in the radiation is still
there said you know I I'd go over to get
over people's lights and gas was cut off
and I'd bring their turkeys over and
just put him in the trunk of the car and
sit that Stagg field for a while and
they'd be done
it was radiation is still here well
here's what we found out 65 years ago
nobody knew about nuclear waste
where did they dump it well when he got
ready to build new buildings University
of Chicago they dumped it in cement and
that was division Chicago's on fire
flames are not there
and I just want to finish that that's
the reason I left Chicago second right
behind that cause I couldn't tell
anybody that they think you crazy so I
had to really blame it on let me find a
place that's not as polluted fresh air
then the children ended up they loved it
there's something about nature there's
something about outside there's
something about and yet I still don't
understand Idaho you tell some of
reactionary people see I grew up in a
city where I believe that if you get
around nature you'd be close to God as I
go around the world and see beautiful
places and you see that meanness in it
and then you can go into little
conclaves where you would never expect
you could find love and that you can
find love you spent how many years at
Southern Illinois University I spent
four years at something on your version
carbonate in Carbondale Illinois and I
think everything I am today
I'd have to trace it back to that but I
can go further to my mother to the
neighborhood I grew up in but it's like
cooking a stew you just got the water
hot in the season in it but you haven't
put the rest of it in well that's what I
was like before sadden have been around
white folks we had a rigid segregated
pattern where I didn't see you I went to
all Negro schools Saigon went to all
Negro movies he we didn't have a
segregated movie where you sit
downstairs now sit upstairs when you had
to go buy clothes at the big department
store you couldn't try them on you save
all my shoes my feet the size whatever I
don't know what size for what they would
take the money in it though he's using
you change back up the stores you could
go into you couldn't try nothing on so
if he was buying a hat you couldn't try
or when she bought it it was no such
thing as you bring it back
why because you a Negro and white folks
didn't want to put on the clothes that
you had had on and it's kind of
interesting how racism work because I
wouldn't mind putting on see that's the
harm about racism not only am i at the
blood of it but it makes me the nice
person
it makes me start believing that you
superior that you clean it in me because
I don't mind putting on a hat you had on
or past use but here's a system that
reminds me and and and so coming out of
that only white folks I knew were the
ones you work for or the ones my mother
worked for they never called her miss
Gregory or miss Lucille it was Lucille
the new children called a Lucille and
you know coming out of a respectful area
which I don't I don't go along with that
today where if you as a child you refer
to to adults as mr. or mrs. well if
Hitler walked in the room I'm gonna tell
a grandchild of mine we thought he was
dead but refer to him incident and even
in the Bible which says honor your
mother and father I scratch that out of
mine when I was a little boy said honor
your mother and father if they honorable
you had a lot of problem with what folks
was really into the Bible and Christians
and I have to put a visual picture if I
as a father raped a three-year-old a six
year old and a five year old and took an
axe and chopped him up or my children
still supposed to honor me because I'm
they dad I don't think so and and and so
just seeing how disrespectful they were
to my mother she didn't feel that way
she was talking about putting food on
the table and feeding us
and then she would take like mashed
potatoes and I'm saying to my brother's
rich by folk song eat no see nobody with
money eats leftovers we eat leftovers
and to some kind of something like they
taste better the second day
no girl you haven't had no turkey to
that second day if you got April why you
had put so much mayonnaise on it it's so
much it's it's so one day
I've always talked back to my mother and
she was fixing food and I've sold as
food as she taken from these white folks
house and put it up hide it
and uh she demanded we say the blessing
so I found my plain old praying over
stolen food and no she'll who said that
and I've always wondered my parents do
that big that's giving you another
chance so let's see I'm not gonna say
you know my mother would attack you she
nice sweet lady but she took nothing
I said who said that and if I look at me
no child of mine or sit at this table
and eat what I pray know who I don't I
don't pray over stolen food what do you
mean by that you taking this food see I
was heavily influenced by movies John
Wayne Humphrey Bogart those with my
heroes and I used to want to be like
them and they wouldn't take nothing off
nobody I know if Humphrey Bogart's
mother Hey had took some mashed potatoes
that the white folks one will eat the
next day he wouldn't pray over it
now it'd be nice if my mother knew Lee
wouldn't go he didn't was taking it but
she was hiding it so she hit me
then I can look my mother had a lot of
sense maybe he'd be hitting you but
she'd be listening if he'd be talking
back to her
I see if you come downstairs in the
basement and pray over what I stole I'll
come back over in prayer what you stole
someone better thief didn't you I just
can't justify mind to religion and she
hurt me then I was sorry I said it she
just sit right down and hug me and she
start crying how many kids are around
that table oh it was it was it was all
of us but when the whoopin stow it ain't
nobody how many are there were there in
it was it six of us for father no father
big Prez big press or was he all I keep
not my hero he was over every movie dude
man you know he's big money Presley
Presley
I'm born 1932 in the early 40s big press
made $60,000 a year can you imagine that
kind of money and him days he was a
master chef master chef I mean if he got
off the boat in England it would be a
violation not to go check in to see if
his service was needed at Buckingham
Palace I got ready to go to college I
was talking to him one day in between
periods he'd be gone and come back and I
don't know where you're going to college
for my sauce man make $60,000 a year now
58 black person 60,000 well I didn't
realize these hotels just the sauces
that you have these certain people just
make those up and so big presser was
never there and my mother loved him god
I mean just outright loved him
Yes Doctor I could relate with that
because I see that in the movies you
know and remember everything in the
movies was white folks and I never seen
a mall mall Queen and a love scene and
the first time I saw two people kissing
passionately I'm a mother and father to
my folks in the movie so locked in my
subconscious mind the epitome of love
it's something lighter than me that
reason I didn't say white folks because
that might explain that yellow thing and
do you like complected folk like they
don't get upset
hey that whole light complected but I
can have a light complected woman and I
don't violate this white man and and and
and and in the black community there's
some black women that's lighter than
white women and so I can have one of
those and don't violate the whole piece
of that and and so thinking of the house
him not being there and that's why today
I detest the problem in the black
community ain't no black man at home
leave home when we home you know a white
racist system that it tortured us all
day long I'm not talking about now I'm
talking about then it goofs you in your
butt and rubbed your hair for luck and
all under how much poontang did you get
boy and you have to tell him because you
couldn't tell that white man that I was
home with the flu over the weekend the
automobiles that black man drove was
better than automobiles at white men go
because racism meant that I didn't have
to pay as much dues as you you got to
come to work in a suit I just wear a
uniform you have to go to Florida go ski
in and do this I didn't have to do all
that so I put that little piece of
change away so I have brand new Cadillac
before you knew what they look like
white folks was buying Jimmy's whiz-bang
Cadillacs but we couldn't take them to
work we'd have to drive them and get our
six blocks before work because even if
you wouldn't I just believed that if you
saw me with that car I would be fine
and that was the atmosphere that I that
I grew up in and so to be told the
problem there's no man at home and then
I get grown one day and realized Hitler
had a mother and father hello huh Jack
the Ripper had a mother and father hello
and Queen Elizabeth make 300 million
dollars every 24 I was just interest on
her money oh that's big paper and she
lives in this huge Buckingham Palace
with Philip they might not sleep
together but you've never been separated
no scandal and you can't find them or
dysfunctional children in Harris so that
whole thing up and then I get to think
it the Mafia
now you tell me about family value came
fired family Oh Mamma Mia you can't find
nobody
oh don't care about nobody else's and so
when you sit and look at all of these
myths that a white racist system first
it is impossible for me to be a racist
there's a lot of black folks it's not
even a way of that I can dislike you
cause you white I don't have to know
what you are that's prejudice I can
dislike you cause you Jewish cause you
Irish Catholic I dislike you cause you
Hungarian you that's prejudice the word
racism means the ability to control
somebody else's faith in destiny and
regardless of what type of dislike I
have for you I do not have the power to
seat you your children go to bad schools
I do not have the power to see to it
that the bank will not give you a
mortgage and that's the difference it's
a big big difference in that and so that
atmosphere coming up in that atmosphere
that it opens up little cracks in your
head where I said well maybe if I'm a
good athlete they'll like me
mm-hmm maybe if I'm a good and then you
grow up one day and you look at the
other side of this now because I'm with
you every day and you with me every day
so those tails work both ways
I believe that all white men had a
little bitty pee-wee's I mean I never
seen him but and it was a whole lot of
white men mine was hanging down to the
ground and in my mind that might be the
only thing I hate giving up with
integration that I had to go to the
toilet with you and I mean one time I
call my wife think I'm in a state of
shock but let me tell you bout this
white border just peed next took me the
whole bit so as a child there was white
folk to say all [ __ ] got tails well
how would you know they happy the
closest you come to a black was my mama
who you call gal and she was always
happy even when she was sick you didn't
know it because she had to go to get the
money to come back and feed us and and
now I've taught my children death is
better there's something in God that say
before you let a system reduce you below
the dignity that I gave you just so you
can feed your family or pay the rent or
a house note or still in the comics
death is better and it's that group of
black folks and white folks who died
that keeps that light that like all so
now today is so much different because
nobody can sit and tell me about them
white folks they have to have a name
what's his name because I know too many
I see too many and then that whole myth
that growing up I believed it was
redneck crackers ignant then one day I
get enough just realized why dude who
can't read or write do not make policy
but we didn't never thought it I thought
the president of Harvard University the
president of AT&T I thought that's what
God if humanity be about again it's the
money is two classes to where you look
and then we also put a
the same way white folks would put up or
what a [ __ ] looks like we also put
what a redneck cracker looks like and it
didn't look like Hawaii gentlemen in a
tire we knew what they talked like what
it sounded like and the whole thing and
so today you hear a lot of people in the
black community talk about integration
and I just said well I'm just thank God
I don't have no serious power you know
see God really knew it when it just put
me here normal make me a good guy don't
give me no power cause Jesus Christ if
I'd have been on that cross with some
serious power then white dudes with a
head hey it's about the size of lemon
humps and they back in club feet so I
just said God just give me no power but
just give me the ability to run so I
won't write to be scared I want to write
to get out of here
don't let me and I explained that to my
wife and my children you know don't seek
dad you all see something y'all get to
get in you know don't worry about me
I'll catch you and one of the jokes they
used to tell me my wife and Larry two
weeks I'm walking down the street and
she call one guy walked up touched a
button so I start stepping and she had
attitude I can't believe you let this
guy touch my rump and do nothing about
it
plus I thought you knew him but then
we've been married two weeks I'm kind of
you know let you did you say you know
that's my husband IRA
she said well I don't know him now what
you gonna do we're gonna get out of here
for he touch mine he that crazy right
and so it was that that home having no
power reacting to fear uh now to sit and
see why folks that are died for you to
sit and watch white folks on TV that
will stand up I mean it still catch me
off guard to read The Wall Street
Journal they say the Attorney General of
designate he should not be the Attorney
General
and to look at the editor wait how about
he lied on this black man this judge it
is kind of interesting because no says
well um he don't want to give nobody
electric chair seventy-three percent of
the cases that came before this black
judge he agreed capital punishment
so that's not the part that you get when
you're just listening to one side and
that's the great part about where we
going now
the sad part is if you would go and get
all your major papers and had a computer
that could snatch a word out like up c
s-- man just scanned it and say well in
the last five years how many times have
there were c-span showed up in the paper
they would pull it out well if you could
go in the last fifty years and get all
the major white papers in america and
say when is the last time how many times
will you see the word free ism in the
New York Times Washington Post sailors
force patch in the last twenty years
it'd be a few times and most the time to
review foreign to us it's a racist
statement and policy and so when you
stop and think of how that affects me
coming out of parents that just wanted
to be liked and so I want to be liked
coming up parents I don't want to rock
the boat so I don't want to rock the
boat and and then all of us the boat
starts rocking and you know it's kind of
interesting when I I look at the
Clarence Thomas I mean there's always
been Clarence Thomas's what alienates us
so bad is that he made it through our
struggle if you go to Colgate and look
at the days when Adam Clayton Powell all
of them went to them type of schools
they look like you
they were light complected see no dark
black men at their institutions
it was the civil rights movement that
fixed it so he could go to that type of
school and sit on the Supreme Court
today unqualified and I got to thinking
people call me and ask me about folk
like Armstrong Williamson and I said
well here's how you have to look at this
two ways I have a right to go crazy and
a white racist system can run me crazy
that's legitimate so there are some
Negroes out here that's seriously crazy
they should be pitied not censored but
there's some out here that know the
right thing to say to tune in to this
wave and a lot of racist white folks
mind and give them aid and comfort and
if Clarence Thomas wasn't doing that he
wouldn't be on the Supreme Court
if Armstrong Williams and that type
wasn't doing that now I don't blame
white folks I blame them on black women
teach my granddaughters
you see if you look at the Clarence
Thomas type about 98 percent of black
thick Jol's nappy hair wide nose and
look very neat growing well they
couldn't get a sister to go to the prom
with him when they was in high school so
they grow up marry white woman and hate
us all so I'm trying to start a campaign
to say to the sister you don't have to
kiss them let's go to the problem we
should not have another generation of
this now here's the painfulness of the
Clarence Thomas when I think about one
day when we sit down and really write to
history now Clarence Thomas will never
be on a stamp but Malcolm X is because
fair people sit and listen what Falcom
sense that I would say the same thing
there was not one black person in the
room that made the decision that Malcolm
X would be honest and it was white folks
that make that decision now all of these
white folks who they think like them you
see and then they attack people like us
to say well there's more than one side
we've been we grew up with black
Republicans huh
Martin Luther King's mother and father
was Republican Jackie Robinson wasn't
Republican all the honorable people in
the black community that would take time
to talk to you that would say you should
do this son you should do this I heard
y'all making too much those were
Republicans that told you about going
into business by get a good education
this new thing out here is a trick is
insulting to us who had a lick of
intelligence the liquor said there's so
many great Fletcher that wrote what we
know now as firm attraction is a
Republican but I think about brother Bob
Brown who sit right next to Nixon
Republican what I think about Homolka
trail these beautiful black business
folks that would never stoop so I do two
things now I said here's how you deal
with this when you see the Klan's Thomas
is in them and the Armstrong Williams in
them who would do a whole column if
three black ops three white cops was
killed by black dude but when white cops
killed black folks you don't hear from
them
that's something wrong with that when
the white press come out and said after
a survey we found out that 63% of people
in certain areas of the Midwest that
apply for loans did not get them
although white folks would lesser jobs
unless we you don't hear from them and
so what they doing is on the backs of
the decent white folks and black folks
it's almost like a chump that didn't go
to war talking that war game
because it makes the people feel good at
the veterans affair and he's laying up
in VA hospitals and he's getting all
these benefits and the people in the VA
hospital is so nothing they so glad to
hear somebody talk war talk it never
dawned on them that he never paid those
dues he was never there and so
consequently when you hear that and you
see that and you read that and you feel
that I say forget that this is the year
2000 and make believe is 1930 and make
believe that's not a black person you
hear make believe this is not America's
Nazi Germany they may believe that what
in television is radio and as a Jew
saying the same thing to make the
Germans feel good that they are saying
trying to appeal to that mentality white
folks and then you get the right picture
now if that you had gone crazy then that
you should be censored away and treated
not censored but if that Jew is doing
that that's the same way and then when I
listen to him today and I think about
Branch Rickey
wow man scary here's a black man that
grew up in a black neighborhood had come
through the wound of a black mother
who's been oppressed and misused and
here's a white man that never had a
black mother that under all normal
circumstances have no reason to relate
or put his job on the line and he says I
have to do it and then you start putting
it in the right and what he did with
Jackie Robinson changed the whole world
I remember that day April 250 1947
something came over me that made me
forgive but
Alan Ladd and Humphrey Bogart and Clark
Gable demos my my head dimples my
partners when Clark Gable say frankly my
dear I don't give a damn the black folks
man we were saying that for the next
three years
teachers say you got your homework
frankly my dear I don't give a damn but
all at once this day something happened
I didn't realize the significance of it
until grown and realized the world the
role that sports play in the psychic of
human beings and realized that here in
the civil rights movement there was
people saying what do they want
I mean did but all in once this is
America's game this is not football then
this was America's game and here not
just a black cat that came up but will
come through and you just felt so good
you felt human and it wasn't a Joe Lewis
did you lose time it passed
there's a guy we didn't know Jackie
Robinson finish UCLA we didn't know
because the way racism affect us
he sounds white we think that's the way
you should sound and he don't walk like
a sharecropper we didn't know he was
from California
we just know and what was is here's a
dark land that fits everything in our
psychic that a white man would accept
he's just chomping he didn't sound Negro
he didn't walk boys he didn't sound
southern we didn't know what he wasn't
and so all at once this excitement this
excitement and then things start
breaking down and I'm sure one day when
100 years 20 years from now when people
sit down and start running an honest
trail it will be that Joe Lewis is very
interested very clever what they did
with Joe Lewis racism was so bad that
Dick Gregory you cannot get in here hit
that white man in the face they'll run
you out of here
then raise your hand so if you go back
and look at all Jewesses pictures after
a fight now you can't tell him he can do
it for black so after all in jail
Lewis's fight you never saw him doing
this
that's why when all he did it it meant
so much to me jealous couldn't do that
he's just safe mama I sure was glad I
win a one B number mama and that didn't
threaten no one at all and so all of
those made the steps clear for someone
else and then you sit and you listen in
society has been so warped and then I
look at America today the most Christian
the most religious nobody talks about
Family Values like America and yet we 6
percent of the world's population 79
percent of all the world's hard drugs we
use what God we praying to we consume
more alcohol as a nation than almost any
nation in the world every 4 seconds you
and I've been sitting here woman and
America's been beat up by a bar for
husband went almost strangers tell us
somebody in the house with me and and
and so all in once you said you say wait
a minute
and then you see how this corrupts the
fabric in other words if you ask someone
what do you think of when you hear the
word God it is amazing the different
things that people say so he's my father
I think of a son I think of the Holy
Ghost I think of Jesus I just do what do
you think of when you hit a word father
and it's kind and loving I think of the
Creator I think of my father I said well
how can you in a Christian prayer
society let a handful of evil old
degenerate pimps take the Mafia
syndicate hoodlums the scum of the earth
and name them Godfather it didn't bother
you as scary Godfather
they didn't bother you and in glamorized
and and we said to the movie n' we
couldn't get enough of their glamor wine
because in a country that's
seriously whooped if you got a nice suit
on remember the Mafia never look bad
tell me it will cool but if we could
ever visualize the Mafia just a little
rough mix for some tattoos on and no
money in stealing cause he's one thing
steal a car as a business nothing steal
new car but you could God what we would
not tolerate that and so when you stop
and see of what branch rickey dead
that's that little flame it's kind of
interested but I use example cuz we've
all been guilty of it you walk across
the house with a candle and sometime
your swiftness creates too much wind and
it almost put the candle out and all you
do is stop slow up and cup it cuz aren't
you just comfort and that flavor that's
what the civil rights movement was doing
what's cupping this candle and it start
flaming and it started going and and in
fair-minded people sit at watch stand
and today you see this this mix and when
I left home to go to college that's the
first time I met a white man as a white
man my coach my professor and the reason
I say nothing changed me the stew
really got mixed at that white races
college and I don't think there could
have been any more college that was more
racist than Sunday law university that
admitted Negroes there was plumber was
worse but they wouldn't let us in and I
got there and I heard a white professor
dr. Voss say to a white girl in speech
does he see nobody want to hear what I
got to say and he told her a story
I wouldn't the whole cotton crop was
wiped out in the bull Weaver's and the
economy of America was about to fold and
we'd been destroyed as a nation and they
didn't know what to do say but this
group of scientists in from the south
and the north and a part of black
scientists in with them named George
Washington Carver he couldn't ride on
the train with them
he had to sit in the Negro section he
couldn't stay here in Washington DC with
him he stayed in the Negro home and
after two weeks they couldn't find the
answer and somebody remember Oh God
George we forgot he's here so they
decided that to come he was going to
close the next day as a failure at 12
noon in there let him on in quarter to
twelve and he spoke a quarter to twelve
there's a white professor at this
college telling this white girl this who
says nobody will listen to me I've done
si and he said a quarter twelve he
started talking it at midnight they sent
out the third time for sandwiches at six
o'clock in the morning they were still
there he had the answer so miss brick
Bauer if you have something to say they
will listen I had a white man say this
and I'm sitting and I walked out I'm not
talking about a movie if talk about a
script about a white man that said if
you have something to say I had a white
coach that told me I was the fastest
thing that ever came down their field
Coleman he was nice and cross country
but I had to glamor I was a third
fastest half-mile in the nation when I
would ever seen it plus I was on the
city you know I'd take no stuff off why
folks you know why because I didn't know
not oh I did nobody never taught me how
to behave I hadn't been around him so I
get there and he would pull me over
never told me so I behave yourself
he said dick take deep breaths to where
father takes it seriously talking to
your boy to take her it's just going to
be for a few minutes he says or taking
some speech courses some foreign
languages and when you get out of here
this and he talked to me with him old
black Republicans used to talk to me
that was the atmosphere and a group of
us blacks came together and we changed
suddenly on on University and I would
dare say today you can't find too many
colleges in America that has this high
percentage of blacks is si you black
vice president Gale Sayers but
the first black athletic director of a
major all that came from the seed that
we planted because we thought more of
that college than just to come through
and suck all the milk out this breast
while I'm coming through we wanted to
leave something not just for other
Negroes but as an institution and we sit
down and we talked and we said here's
what this institution is doing for us
what we going to do for it well we're
going to kick its booty and we're going
to bring it down and we came together
one day 125 years no Negro had been
outstanding athlete of the year so we
went into state got mad kicked us out so
then we decided that we quit you know
they told us so what we can get some
more so I got on the phone and called
Central Michigan not Central Mitch
Michigan normal in Ypsilanti and said
hey I'm Dick Gregory and all the Negro
athletes be thinking about quitting if
we quit will you take us I said sure so
we went back in total coaching and that
night they made me outstanding athlete
of the year that's when I realized
bargaining same thing with the Thetas
our variety show a black person that
never wanted in singing that nothing so
we just bought 50 tickets and when they
locked the door and I got up dance bug
they're saying about that dadada and
took the trophies and that's how we beat
it down and beat it down and want to
define institutions not perfect won't be
perfect until the next group comes in
decides that we're going to change it
and that's what I wanted this book to
reflect I wanted a book that a hundred
years from now when black folks and
white folks from all over the world sit
down and want to look at the movement
they'll have a document I had no hidden
agenda when I put this together when you
see me on the front of that cover there
behind them bars I have a suit and a tie
one you could never wear a tie in jail
because you can commit suicide they take
your shoestrings that without saying it
in the book that I said America is in
jail
and I'm looking through the bars at
America and I hope you liberate yourself
and I hope you ready for this parole
my nephew took that picture I was doing
a movie to one of the scenes was in jail
so before I put my costume on melvin van
peebles i was doing that and then we
thought hey this would make her and one
of the things that i would like to say
to you out there all of you should write
a book but a book that's gonna be sold
it might but just sit down because you
are somebody and just sit down what I
was able to do because of the advance of
Sheila Moses I said here's what I want
13 books out here and I don't want you
to rewrite with me another book that's
the same thing certain things will never
change I was born October 12 1932 I will
always be born that have to be it when I
first broke my first book [ __ ] I was
looking for a white man not a black man
not me to write it with me because the
message I had in my first book black
folk didn't need to hear it white
America needed to hear it who had never
been around a Negro doctor or Negro
schoolteacher or Negro principal and and
so I wanted to put my life in his head
let him spit it out so would have the
this time I wanted black folks and white
folks and humans and Sheila Moses was
that person that I said go around the
world interview whatever you have to
interview and then come back but the
skeleton and they will put the meat on
the bones and we ended up with callus on
muscle this is the cover of the book our
guest has been Dick Gregory and the book
is callus on my soul thank you very much
thank you brother